46 of americans in a new ipsos poll say  they have to return to their pre-coveted  lives and really the the devil is in the  details for interpreting such such a  number because  on the one hand  i mostly feel like i'm back to my  pre-covered life  but then when i really think about it  i'm not going to large concerts  and i'm not going to sporting events  and i'm not going to clubs and places  with a whole bunch of people places i  used to go before  so in a sense i'm not really back to my  pre-covered life  but at the same time i don't really have  an interest in those things either so  even if it were not for covid would i be  doing those things i'm just really  annoyed by large crowds maybe i wouldn't  so i actually don't know even in that  poll  am i back to my pre-covered life or not  unsure what about you let me know in the  comments